[Music]
[Applause]
i never would have imagined it uh at all
that this
i would have ended up like this
but uh he's been like this all day
i was a serious actor once
but uh
uh oh
it was impossible to have imagined the
you know being a part of this enormous
saga that
spans the nine whole episodes and so
it's a no it's a
source of pride and also relief to have
it all done
i wasn't a serious actor before so i'm
was thrilled to be employed i think your
turn in the morrison's advert was
incredible
[Music]
something about the way she chewed into
that pie
but um i couldn't have imagined it no no
no i wasn't expecting to be involved in
star wars but you know when the
opportunity came i think everybody was
quite excited every actor and actress
that was going up for it at the time
it's quite an exciting time
[Music]
i feel like there's been a lot of work
done by many many other people that has
allowed me to
be in this
so obviously for that i'll always be
thankful
um and i also think in general being
part of a very inclusive star wars world
is
really wonderful
i feel
that a lot of people are seeing people
that they can connect with on screen in
a way that they maybe hadn't had before
yeah i just feel really lucky to be part
of that
just please tell me you're in a story
against like love
what is it no it's youtube
what is it well oscar was saying earlier
but every time jonas was trying to speak
through the mask and jj was like
what do
we were in the desert together too in
the wadi rum desert and that was really
fun and it's like a wild place to shoot
there'd be massive sandstorms and
um
you know every friday we'd have our
dancing oh yeah remember funky friday
funky fridays yeah
yeah
so there was a lot of laughs lots of
laughs lots of loves
what was your favorite one i don't think
anything's been said that's true
right
is it maybe maybe on that one reddit
channel right
something
right possibly leak
i thought po and finn could be
boyfriends but
that was not explored and it happened no
sorry for you guys
people feel it though yeah
they do
that
i
it wasn't unfulfilled because it was
fulfilled in this but i'm very excited
that we all get to share the screen in
this and go on an adventure together
that was one thing i was really
thinking like was it is that gonna
exactly
getting to have a scene with
rey and pope yeah that hadn't really
happened before
it feels really good
i mean it's a really strange thing
because also
you know you don't live your life for
the most part thinking about your impact
into the star wars world so then
obviously we do interviews like this and
suddenly you think oh my gosh yeah yeah
i am really part of this
uh it feels
really good like i think jj and chris
have done the most amazing job tying
everything up
um and hopefully people are really happy
with it just kind of waiting for the
dust to settle yeah you know end of
january yeah a little island somewhere
yeah tropical fruit juice
someone massaging my back yes they're
thinking back
yeah construction i'm thinking back at
the the many years shared between
three
let the game begin
okay
darth vader
yes
oh i didn't know that darth maul
okay
okay
job of the hood
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
well she just had all yes creepy
hairstyles huh yeah papa tea
is that purple how about these balls
chin up these balls
[Music]
is strong
[Music]
very good
[Music]
[Music]
or like a backpack i can't even see like
there's a hint a storm trooper
no
oh it's a storm trooper it's a
stormtrooper right the blaster is it
luke when he's training
oh
flying oh fly naughty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you actually got these for us yeah i
mean it's from excuses for emotional
items that's so kind of thing
we don't get gifts
yeah but not in person it's like you get
them
we don't get a gift ever
bush
my face looks so like i had a bad
night's sleep the night before and then
nah you're cute
that is so
cool man